bonsoir benjamin morel merci beaucoup
d'être d'être avec nous sur rt france
qu'elle est quelle est votre réaction
benjamin morel les maires prennent des
mesures pour essayer d'endiguer la
pandémie et les talents n'empêche
qu'elle est quelle est l'explication
selon vous non si vous voulez il faut
pas polémiquer là dessus en fait c'est
un mécanisme très classique endroit qui
datent du 19e siècle et qui est
appliquée de toute façon dans tous les
cas de la même façon vous avez un
pouvoir national qui impose des mesures
ces mesures elles doivent être
proportionnées et elles doivent à tenter
le moins possible aux libertés
individuelles pour des circonstances
locales qui peuvent être des
circonstances particulières atypique sur
un territoire
vous avez le maire qui peut aggraver
cette ces restrictions des libertés mais
à condition que ce soit justifié que ce
soit propre territoire
cali le conseil d'état ici il a dit
quelque chose auquel on s'attendait en
fait parce qu'il n'est pas réellement
dire autre chose
au vu de l'état du droit depuis 200 ans
il a dit vous pouvez renforcer
localement les mesures décidées par
l'état à condition qu'il y ait une
condition vocale qui soit une condition
locales particulières atypique et que ce
ne soit pas trop attentatoires aux
libertés
si on avait maintenu l'arrêter en l'état
ça veut dire que si vous n'aviez pas de
masque on sait bien qu'aujourd'hui tout
le monde n'a pas accès aux masques et
bien vous pouviez pas sortir pour vous
alimentez acceptera et cetera donc
c'était bien 3 attentatoires aux
libertés individuelles de tout un chacun
et des habitants de la commune mais
c'est à partir de là c'est bien possible
il n'y a pas de menace c'est ce que s'il
y avait démasqué ce que l'état
proposerait le port du masque
obligatoire c'est là toute la question
alors l'état aurait aurait elle décidé
mais probablement qu'en effet s'il y
avait des masques pour tout le monde
l'état serait conduit à imposer pas dans
une commune
mais sur l'ensemble du territoire où au
moins dans les régions les plus touchées
le bord du masque obligatoire mais si
vous êtes maire que tout le monde n'a
pas de masquer que vous dites donc vous
ne sortez pas parce qu'il nous faut un
masque à ce moment là vous allez
beaucoup trop loin dans la restriction
des libertés c'est pas légal
c'est ce qu'a dit le conseil d'état qui
avait pas vraiment de suspense si vous
voulez sur cette décision
est-ce qu'on peut pas imaginer que c'est
pas forcément un match mais ça pourrait
être un foulard qui serait ce qui serait
demandé ce que là ça sera
constitutionnel ou pas alors
potentiellement
ça pourrait l'être à condition encore
une fois que vous ayez une situation
particulière c'est à dire que vous avez
des comités vous avez des experts qui
estiment l'utilité ce genre de choses au
niveau national si vous avez par exemple
une commune extrêmement touchée parce
que vous avez une concentration
exponentielle de cas à ce moment là le
maire est légitime et légalement
pourrait éventuellement imposer des
mesures supplémentaires s'est pas
réellement le cas de la commune de sô
s'il vous plaît on a vu par exemple
certaines villes ou et bien vous pouviez
avoir des couvre-feux parce que vous
aviez des consentements des
concentrations de populations
importantes et parce que vous aviez une
population qui visiblement ne respectez
pas toutes les consignes de sécurité
donc à partir de là vous avez une
situation locale particulière qui
justifie que le maire puisse agir de
façon particulière c'est comme ça que ça
marche c'est si vous voulez une capacité
pour les mères d'aggraver les mesures
nationales mais à une condition c'est
que c'est triste restée très cette
restriction est une restriction des
libertés des citoyens
et bien soit justifiée par une
circonstance locale c'est la même
question pour la réouverture des écoles
certains maires ont dit c'est ta nou
finalement de décider quels
établissements doivent rouvrir ou pas on
se souviendra effectivement qu emmanuel
macron avait rendu au maire la
possibilité de les fermer ou d ouvrir
ces écoles où est-ce qu'on situe à ce
niveau là politiquement si vous voulez
il ya des contre-exemples à l'étranger
c'est à dire que encore une fois je
rappelle la règle que j'ai donné tout à
l'heure c'est à dire vous avez une
mesure nationale et le maire peut la
grave et il ne peut que l'aggraver il
peut pas là léger parce que s'il allège
et que sa relance la contamination y a
pas que la commune qui est touché c'est
l'ensemble de la nation qui est touché
quand la région lombardie à 10o à l'état
central italien ânonnant nous on décide
de faire ce que l'on veut ça a lancé la
bande est mis en bouteille et peut-être
même dans l'ensemble de l'europe ces
derniers jours on tente beaucoup
l'exemple allemand en grande partie à
tort sur ces sujets là ces derniers
jours ces derniers jours vous avez le
vous avez un président à ministre
président du land heures de chaises lits
coach times qui a décidé de laisser les
gens se réunir à pâques
très clairement il y à un risque là et
le l'état central ne pouvait rien dire
l'un des avantages du système français
c'est que justement vous avez malgré
tout cet effet cliquer cet effet qui
fait que quand l'état central décide
quelque chose eh bien vous ne pouvait
qu'aggraver des mesures ce qui évite de
mettre en danger l'ensemble de la
communauté nationale parce qu'un élu
déciderez d'alléger il en va de même
pour les écoles on peut contester l'idée
de réouvrir les écoles plus tôt en
revanche ce que l'on peut faire c'est
envisagé de l'instruction particulière
dans certaines communes en l'airé
ouvrant plus tard donc les maires ne
pourront pas les rouvrir plus tôt ils
pourront potentiellement les rouvrir
plus tard à une condition c'est que eh
bien il ya une circonstance locale que
la commune soit dans une situation telle
que ça justifie de déroger à la règle
nationale
c'est la règle et ça sera toujours là ça
sera là c'est celle qui voulait qui va
prévaloir en matière de masse comme en
matière d'école vous dites que les verts
ne doivent pas aggraver la situation et
les décisions qui sont prises à nancy où
ils peuvent justement les aggraver
l'émotion que l'écho l'état n'a pas pris
dès le départ et les français le
reproche à l'état notamment sur le port
du masque et sur le port du masque je
vous refais la même réponse que je vous
ai donné c'est à dire que à défaut si
vous ne pouvez pas sortir alors que vous
avez besoin d'une course urgente
parce que vous n'avez pas de masque
parce que le maire a rendu diplomatie
obligatoire mais que vous n'en disposez
pas il ya un problème
d'approvisionnement masclef tueur va
être très rapidement être d'accord mais
du coup vous retrouver dans une
situation où vos libertés sont bientôt
contrainte par rapport à ce qui est
nécessaire parce que vous pouvez pas
vous alimentez donc les maires peuvent
agir en effet il peut y avoir des
défaillances de l'état
les maires peuvent agir à condition que
ce soit proportionné et que ça aille
dans le sens d'une aggravation et on le
voit bien il ya un bras de fer entre
certains maires certaines communes et
l'état justement les communes qui ont
lancé aussi la fabrication de masques à
leur niveau pour permettre à la
population d'en avoir
c'est un
un combat politique finalement ce combat
sanitaire débat aucun combat politique
mais pour beaucoup d'élus en effet c'est
pas tant un combat d'ailleurs contre le
gouvernement a installé ses pains c'est
pas une guerre entre entre la majorité
et l'opposition ou en tout cas c'est
rarement ça c'est surtout la guerre de
certains grands élus pas tant dans les
petites communes où les choses se
passent assez bien les deux grandi lui
je pense notamment au maire de nice à
certains présidents de région contre
l'état à four in fine et gagné plus de
pouvoir dans le cadre de cette crise
encore une fois quand on regarde les
exemples étrangers
on voit que la régionalisation de la
santé ça ne marche pas très bien on
prends souvent l'exemple allemand que
savoir que quand vous régionaliser la
santé quand vous décentraliser la santé
vous produisez des inégalités la grande
chance de l'allemagne dans cette affaire
c'est que les trois régions les plus
riches d'allemagne concentre 70% des
quatre coronavirus donc ce sont des
régions où les hôpitaux évidemment or au
regard de cette inégalité est bien ont
beaucoup gagné à cette décentralisation
elles peuvent ils peuvent mieux absorbé
justement parce que ce sont les gens les
plus riches
si cette crise était arrivée dans les
landes de l'est à sedan les länder de
l'est
à ce moment là la situation restait
extrêmement différente ou qu'il faut
faire attention et il faut pas tomber
dans le comptage des points en ce qui
n'est pas une opposition entre la
majorité et l'opposition
mais en fait entre quelques grands élus
et l'état
merci beaucoup d'engins morel d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france